Good afternoon, everyone.
Thank you all for being here.
Thank you, Ed, and
everyone who's contributed
to creating this space for us.
My name is Kester
Barrow, and I'm
an area director for MacGregor
House and residential life
programs here at MIT.
I'm both anxious
and excited today
to really engage in this
conversation, this dialogue,
with you all.
At the beginning of the
spring 2016 semester,
the MIT community
received an announcement
from President Reif,
sharing with us
a tremendous
scientific discovery.
He shared that in collaboration
with Caltech and the National
Science Foundation,
researchers at MIT
had recorded the
first direct detection
of gravitational waves.
He stated, "I do not
typically write to you
to celebrate individual
research achievements
no matter how impressive.
Our community produces
important work all the time,
but I urge you to reflect
on today's announcement
because it demonstrates
on a grand scale
why and how human beings pursue
deep scientific questions
and why it matters."
Today, given President
Reif's words,
please keep these two
following challenges in mind
as we engage with each
other throughout today's
conversation.
I challenge you to pursue
deep social questions.
I challenge you to
define for yourself
why does understanding
these social issues matter?
Race and other socially
constructed identities
aren't real.
They're tools created
by the oppressors
to maintain the social norms at
the expense of the oppressed;
however, race is a lived
experience for us all
that's been part of
the fabric of the USA
since the founding
of this nation.
We cannot negate the harm
and the pain that we've all
experienced as a result
of this oppressive system.
If we truly seek to
achieve change and growth,
we must embrace the challenge
of acknowledging our history
and seeking change.
By embracing these challenges,
we accept the shame.
We will be tempted to
shy away from the shame.
Some of us will retreat
inwards and attack ourselves
based upon that shame, others
will project their shame
outwards and attack others.
However, please
keep this in mind.
As a man, it is
my responsibility
to process my
shame around gender
if I truly seek gender equity.
As a cisgendered
heterosexual male,
is my responsibility to process
my shame around sexuality
if I truly seek to support
the movement for equity
for the queer community.
Members of our community are
already gathering in groups
to support each other in
a processing of shared
identities and the emotions that
stem from those conversations.
In the coming months, it is
the hope of many in this room
that these spaces
become a norm at MIT.
Where the purpose isn't
to segregate, but instead
to achieve insight and
foster support and healing.
If our aim is to
truly pursue change,
we must try new strategies
because the current strategies
have only taken us thus far.
In closing, I'd like
to take a moment
to acknowledge the weight
of the violence that's
plagued our society
over the last few weeks.
Alton Sterling, you matter.
Philando Castile, you matter.
The five officers who died
in Dallas, you matter.
The 49 souls lost in
Orlando, you matter.
The victims of the bombings in
Turkey, Bangladesh, and Iraq,
you matter.
Members of the MIT community
who don't feel safe, you matter.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]